one of the benefits of a data warehouse
like bigquery is the improved simplicity
and speed of bringing data to your
analysts and decision makers
data needs vary across the company based
on organizational function geography and
more
so it's important to be able to provide
customized access to your users
without adding unnecessary risk in
today's episode of bigquery spotlight
we're showing you how to create
authorized views which give you the
ability to define and share a specific
subset or view
of your bigquery data stay tuned
[Music]
bigquery organizes data into containers
called data sets
these data sets function like top level
folders that organize and control access
to the underlying tables
in our episode managing access with
cloud iam we talked about how to manage
access at the data set and table level
using the identity and access management
service or cloud iam
if you want to check it out we've linked
it below cloud iam can restrict access
down to the table level
but what if you want to restrict access
for members to parts of a table
in bigquery one way to accomplish this
task is by creating
authorized views an authorized view
allows you to share the results of a
query with a specific user or group
without giving that user access to the
tables that were queried
for example let's say as a bigquery data
admin you wanted to give an analyst at
your company
access to a table containing your
service request data
but you wanted to remove the full
address of the service location
you could write a query that didn't
include the address column and then save
the results as an
authorized view to share with the
analyst creating an authorized view
follows a defined series of steps
step 1 start with your source data set
this is the data set with the sensitive
data you don't want to share
step 2 create a separate data set to
store the view
authorized views require the source data
to sit in a separate data set from the
view
don't worry about the reason why you'll
see in step 6.
step 3 create a view in the new data set
in the new data set you create the view
you intend to share with your data
analysts
this view is created using a sql query
that includes only the data the analysts
need to see
step 4 assign access controls to the
project
in order to query the view your analyst
needs permission to run
queries assigning your analyst the
bigquery user role gives them this
ability
this access does not give them the
ability to view or query any data sets
within the project
step 5 assign access controls to the
data set containing the view
in order for your analyst to query the
view they need to be granted the
bigquery data viewer role for that
specific data set that contains the view
and finally step six authorize the view
to access the source
data set this gives the view itself
access to the source data
we need to do this because the view
takes on the permissions of the person
using it
and since the analyst doesn't have
access to the source table they'd
otherwise get an error if they tried to
query this view we're going to jump into
the console and see how it's done
you can follow along in your own
bigquery sandbox which you can set up
for free following the instructions in
the video link below
we're using two sandboxes in order to
represent the perspectives of both the
data admin
and the analyst okay starting out as the
data admin
step one you'll need a data set to store
your full source data containing the
sensitive address field
from the bigquery console select your
project and click create data set
give your data set a name and click the
create data set button
now you'll populate a table within the
data set using a sql query
click compose new query and copy and
paste the source data query that's
linked in the description below
into the query editor before running the
query
go into the query settings and check the
box for set a destination table for
query results
verify your project and data set name
are selected then name your table
service requests click save
now click run when the query completes
you can select your new table in the
left hand nav
and click preview to see that the data
was populated
step 2 time to create a separate data
set where you'll put the view for your
analyst
you'll follow the same steps we just
performed select your project and click
create data set
name your data set shared views and
click create data set
step 3. now you'll create the view for
your analyst
click compose new query and copy and
paste the view query linked in the
description below
into the query editor this query selects
all the columns from the source data
except for the sensitive address
field now click save view make sure your
project and data set are selected
and give the view a name
click save you can see that the view is
now populated in the left-hand nav
we have our source table and our analyst
view set up
time to start assigning access controls
for our analyst
step 4 give the analyst permission to
query in the project by assigning the
bigquery user role
from the navigation menu head to iam and
admin and click iam
click add in the members field
enter the analyst email address or as we
are using a google group
that contains your analysts in the roles
field
click select a role and choose bigquery
user click
save head back to bigquery by using the
search bar in the console
step 5. next you'll give the analyst
permission to read the data set that
contains the view
select the shared views data set and
then click share data set
click add members again enter the email
or group for your analysts
select the role bigquery data viewer
then click add and finally click done
step six you need to give the view
itself access to the source data set
this is what is meant by an authorized
view from the source data set click
share data set
and then this time head to the
authorized views section
change the data set to shared views and
select your view for the table
click add and then click done your
authorized view configuration is now
complete
let's flip over to the analyst account
to see the result from their perspective
the analyst is logged in and has
selected the same project
analytic source data let's verify what
data they are able to view
as you can see the analyst is able to
both access the view and run queries
over it
but when they try to view the source
table they do not have access
now you're ready to use this same
process to create any number of
authorized views customized for your
groups and users at your company
if you want to learn more about bigquery
check out the rest of our playlist
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel on youtube for other great
content
look out for our next episode of
bigquery spotlight and remember
stay curious
[Music]
you